[MUSIC PLAYING]
So they're all like
starting with sub.
And it just means substitution.
That's what it means.
I try to find something short.
I didn't want to,
obviously, write something
longer than that.
So it makes sense
in sub_missing.
So we're going to substitute
missing values for something
else.
And the setup is we
use that with the data.
Data here just means
the gt, table data.
So you always start with gt,
and then you use this function.
And that's data.
And columns-- basically,
you can focus this function
over any columns you want.
But by default, it's everything.
So it'll just go through
every single column.
And no big deal if
there's no missing
values in some of those columns.
It'll just skip over those.
So it's quite nice.
You can just like--
it's almost like
paint by numbers or--
I'm trying to find
the right analogy,
but I can't seem to do that.
It'll just find
things which apply.
And if they don't
apply, no big deal.
And you can even run
it-- if you don't
have missing values at all,
it'll still work, no change,
but you can feel safe
doing that in case you
have some like cable
inputs that may or may not
have the same values.
You don't know
that ahead of time.
So that's kind of cool
that you can do that.
So let me show you this.
We have a built-in dataset
in gt called exibble.
It's a little hard to
fit, although the idea
is that it does fit.
It's only eight rows.
And a small table, it's
just for messing around
with tables and sheet.
So I can make this even smaller.
[INAUDIBLE] a few columns,
get row and group,
and then put down the gt
with this gt function.
So if you know
nothing about gt, this
is how you sort of started.
And right away, we
can use sub_missing.
So in this case, we
can use column names.
For this one, I'm just
using like indices.
So 1 and 2 are num
and char, and 4 to 7
are the rest of
the columns here.
And we're going to place--
in columns 1 and 2,
we have any values.
There's one here and one there.
We're going to replace
NAs with the text missing.
And just to be a bit
different, in columns 4 to 7,
we'll replace the
NAs with nothing.
Two ways of saying it's missing.
I don't know.
So you can totally do that.
It's great.
So I'm going to run this.
And immediately you'll see
the effect, missing, missing
and a whole lot of nothing
here in these columns.
So kind of cool.
By default, I'm just going
to change things here a bit.
I'm going to take all
this missing text.
It's not the default value.
So if I do this
and run it again--
the default is an
em dash, and it's
hard to write that to
represent what an em dash is.
Here that default in
gt is three dashes.
It magically takes that and
converts into an em dash
because there's
no way in Markdown
to say I want an em dash.
You just can't do it.
This actually becomes
like a horizontal rule,
which is not what you want.
So probably maybe you do,
but I don't think you do.
So that said, you can even
use two to get a smaller dash.
In this case, that's an en dash.
And maybe you can see it.
Maybe you can't.
It's a slightly smaller dash.
And, of course, you can go back
to this, which is a hyphen.
So here you go.
So the dash becomes
smaller and smaller
with less of these hyphens used.
So yeah.
So that's sub_missing.
And this is actually
nothing really new.
We used to have this function.
It used to be called
format_missing.
It's just been
renamed to sub_missing
because I want to move
things into a separate family
and have a bunch
of other functions
which do the same sort of thing.
You can still use the former,
but it gives a warning,
which you may not want to see
each and every single time you
want to make a table.
So just migrate your
format_missings over
to sub_missing if you have some
code just to run the feature.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's find out.
It does, yeah.
You have to wrap it with md.
And so let's actually do this.
Let's do-- just
gone, like not there.
OK, do bold just so
you can really see it.
So I'm going to run this.
Yes, it does take
Markdown, which is great.
Easy way to make--
you don't have to style
it after the fact.
You just use that.
So let's do emo.
So let's put it
inside this md thing.
I'm pretty sure that is super
important because that just
becomes HTML.
It worked.
It really worked.
OK, that's great.
This is fun.
I love like-- I didn't know
for sure that would work.
Will it work without md?
Probably not, right?
But I don't know.
Let's give it a whirl.
Let's see.
Whoa.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It just gives you a
different function.
You don't need that md.
OK, that's cool.
That's cool.
That is very cool.
So here's some really new stuff.
It's new both in [INAUDIBLE]
It's a zero [INAUDIBLE]
sub_zero, cool function.
You can either think of it like
a blue ninja or a refrigerator.
It's totally up to
your imagination what
that might invoke in your mind.
But basically, what it really
is, you get a zero value.
It's truly zero.
Not rounded to zero but
like really, really zero.
Then you can replace
that zero with something.
And it might be kind
of fun to do that.
Who knows?
Let's just find out.
OK.
So basically, the same
idea as sub_missing.
Instead of missing
text, it's zero_text.
And the default is nil.
I don't know why I chose that.
I think I saw it somewhere, and
I thought, that's kind of cool.
You never see that.
I got to put that in
instead of just using this.
That seemed too boring
for me because just
replacing the thing you
have with the same thing.
OK.
For this, I'm going
to actually make
a new table using the
table function from dplyr
and the tibble package.
I'm going to make a small table,
which has a bunch of values
but also some zeros.
And these are like perfect
zeros, not 0.0001, whatever.
They're just like zeros.
OK.
So with this table, these values
will be given replacement text.
OK.
And in this case, this
is kind of cool, right?
Because you can just use
this without anything.
And the default will just work.
I mean, you may not
like the default value,
but it's pretty easy to
use, you have to admit.
OK.
So let's try that.
Let's run this and
see if it works.
It totally works.
OK, that's awesome.
And the cool thing is
if you use format_number
on the same column,
this will still work.
It won't cancel out things
like other formatters do.
That's a different thing
with these subfunctions.
You can run it within the same
columns as the formatters.
And it won't interfere.
It won't do anything weird.
It won't cancel
out the formatting.
It's kind of nice.
OK.
So let's try with a
different zero text.
Again, Markdown
will totally work.
Zero should totally work.
Yeah, that's great.
I wonder if there's
emoji for that.
Let's give it a shot
just if only to check
our knowledge of this package.
Yeah.
Yeah, sub-zero.
Really simple.
It's meant to be simple.
Why would you use that?
I don't know.
I've seen it, where sometimes
like rounding down to zero
is different than a true zero.
It's almost like a
truly missing value
is different than something
that's not entered.
Who knows?
There's a difference there.
It just hits
different, these zeros,
whether they're
really zeros or not.
So now we have ones which are
a bit more complex but still
useful, I think.
So this one here
called sub_small_vals.
So you ever get this issue where
you have really small values
but you don't want to
put in all the zeros.
You just want to say
it's really small.
It's like below this number.
It's not zero, but
it's really small.
So that's what you can do
with this one, sub_small_vals.
So same as before.
It's got the data.
You can focus it on
columns and rows.
There's actually
a threshold value.
This tells gt what small is.
That's the definition
of small in this case.
And this is a bit complex.
Usually, you don't put
like an if/else statement
in your pattern.
So that's also another thing.
We have a pattern in this case.
The pattern is basically
this like curly brace x.
That will be the
value basically of--
it'll basically
be the threshold.
Essentially, this
will go into there.
And then you can wrap stuff
around it like literal values.
So basically, if the
sign, which means
like if the values are
positive, any values
which are below this
threshold will get
this less than threshold value.
OK.
We also have negative
values because we
have small negative values.
It's a weird case.
It's handled separately.
You just put a sign
minus, negative sign.
And then the other
case will be--
this is very strange, less
than the absolute value
of minus the threshold value,
which is kind of weird,
but couldn't really find a
better way to represent that.
But I imagine the
case is not too--
you don't get very
many cases where
you have small negative
values, but it's there in case
you need it.
So let's take a look at this.
We'll play around.
So we've got this table here.
Oh, let me just get rid of
this so we don't see it again.
And I'll bring this down a bit.
OK.
So we have some
really small values,
and we're getting
to bigger values.
So obviously, we're going to
target these values at the top
here as being small.
So the default value is 0.01.
So it's somewhere around here.
We don't know if it's going
to include this or not,
but we're about
to find that out.
But yeah.
I'll show you the
beforehand one.
We can still format the
number in that column.
I'll make this bigger.
OK.
So all the values are
formatted, which just
means that before we had this.
And we don't really want that.
So now we have this
after formatting
We have two decimal
places as a default.
We can't even see the
actual small values here.
So this is just ripe for
replacing with something
smaller than some threshold.
So let's actually run this.
And there it is.
So these are smaller
than that value.
It doesn't seem to include it.
It seems like it's less
than, not less than and equal
to that value,
which is sometimes,
I think it's actually
maybe a good thing
to have it like that
because you probably
want to keep these values
and just have it less than,
like not including that value.
So that's how that works.
And we can change the pattern.
Let me try that actually.
You can even not
include this at all.
Well, let's actually
just run this by itself.
So that is basically that
without anything around it.
This is the default right here.
There.
And then later on,
I'll show you that you
don't have to even use this.
But first thing, I'll show
you the negative case.
So let's pretend for instance we
have the tables we have before.
We're going to make all
the numbers negative.
So going into gt is
going to look like this.
So it's all in formatted.
So we're going to
format that column first
with format number.
Great.
And now we have these values
here, which did round, I think,
to positive.
So it's really kind
of like weird, right?
But we know these
are negative values.
So it's a weird
thing [INAUDIBLE]..
So let's actually just run this.
In this case, the
sign is negative.
Consider all like negative small
values really close to zero.
So we're going to run this Yeah.
And now we get this less
than the absolute value
of this threshold in
the minus direction.
So kind of cool.
We used the same
default. We didn't even
have to change it to minus 0.01.
It just needed-- by
virtue of the fact
that we had the
minus sign, it just
handled it as the negative case.
So here's another example.
The threshold is much smaller.
I think we'll get one value in
there, which is the top value.
Md's replaced with a literal
string like small like this.
So check it out.
Yeah, formatting as before.
Yeah.
We don't know how small
these are because we cut off
like the actual digits.
But this will reveal it.
There you go.
That one's small.
And we can always do this, too.
If you want to just
touch up in formatting,
you can do decimals.
3-- and I believe, in
this case, the top--
yeah, one below the
replaced value [INAUDIBLE]
decimal place.
And if you really don't
like that, you can do--
I believe there's
one called n_sigfig.
And that's number of significant
digits you want to keep.
And I believe that
is very similar.
Oh, not quite.
It runs the opposite direction.
OK.
So we have like--
we did the small values.
Now there's also
this complement,
which is sub_large_values
because you never know.
You may have these large values.
You don't want all zeros.
And you may not want to use
that scientific notation, which
is supposed to solve that.
But yeah, we can
totally do that.
We can substitute large
values in the table body
with something else.
And it uses many of the same
arguments, threshold for one.
Obviously, much bigger, like
1 times 10 to the 12th--
so big.
Large pattern is different.
It's not like complex
like the other one.
Could basically
just write yourself
if you want it to be less than.
And sign is there as well.
So very similar.
Just run through some examples.
OK.
So again, I make my own table.
Here we go.
Basically, zero, NA
just for a good measure
to have those in there,
just to see that's
not affected by that.
And super huge values.
OK.
So I'm going to make this
a bit smaller because we
looked at that.
I'll go step by step.
I'm going to show
you that yes, you can
format the numbers really big.
If you didn't
format the numbers,
you probably don't want that I
don't really want this either.
But if you did and you really
don't want the really big
values, you could run this.
And there you go.
And these values are bigger
than 1 times 10 to the 12th.
Unfortunately, this is not
really nicely formatted.
And there's no real way of
formatting this actual thing,
which is kind of crappy,
but you can put it
in your own thing at least.
And I think in
the later updates,
I may make it possible
to format this itself.
But at the moment, it's not easy
to do, or it's really tough.
[LAUGHS]
But it's OK because we can
actually change things.
We can actually say--
do I have an example here?
Yes, I do.
OK.
Let's get to the negative
case because you never
know you might have large
negative numbers, depending
on what you're doing.
So those are the large
negative numbers.
We're going to
format those again,
same as before, except
it has a negative sign.
And in this case, we only have
to do much the same thing.
We just have to use
sign equals in quotes.
And we have this.
And this automatically
changes to less than because--
it's weird.
Now we're going-- yeah.
It's going to be lesser
of a negative number.
Man, this math stuff is tough.
First scientific
digits and now this.
Yeah.
So we have values which are less
than this large negative value.
OK.
It makes sense.
You just have to think
about it for a second
because we're in negative land.
OK.
So we don't have to settle with,
as I said here, the default
threshold value or the
default replacement pattern
and large pattern.
I can change it.
So in this case, I change the
threshold to be a bit smaller,
and we're doing positives.
In this case, large pattern
is just a word hugemongous.
We're going to run this.
And then here we go.
All the way down,
you get this thing.
Yeah, Markdown?
Definitely.
It should.
Totally work.
Just to prove it, it works
across all these functions.
Let's run this again.
All right.
Yeah, great.
Yeah, these are like--
these substitution functions
are like finishing touches.
Just in case if you
need it, it's there.
You know you need it.
But if you don't need
it, don't worry about it.
But some people need it.
One case especially
is like the--
not the sub_zero one but
the sub_small_values.
You may have values which are
below a certain threshold.
It could be like
measurement stuff,
like below detection rate.
You can have all sorts
of specialized words,
depending on your area of focus,
your research subject, which
denote that these values
are small but not zero.
This is probably the
most important one,
but this is also important
too for really huge values,
just really big.
You can just see that.